you a prime minister
vomit drunken altercations security
staff being treated with contempt
cleaners having to mop up red wine
sue grey's is shame in dossier really
isn't it of what's meant to be the place
the heart of government that sets the
standards of our country
and it's your culture under your
leadership did you never for a moment
during the past five months or even this
morning when that report landed on your
desk and you read it blow by blow
think about resigning a poll out today
just out says three in five britons
think you should yes i look and uh beth
i of course i understand uh why people
are
um
indignant and and
i
and why people have been angry at what
uh what took place all i can say is that
i really think that given everything
that is going on right now
it's my job to get on and serve the
people of this country uh not just to
get us through the biggest war in europe
for uh for
70 years
but a huge spike in uh the the cost of
uh of living and to deliver
our manifesto commitments on which i was
uh elected uh with a large majority i i
so i i i hear you i i understand you uh
but i i really feel it's my job to
to to get on was there any point you
thought about it though because during
any of it did you ever think this why
are only you allowed to come back beth
special position okay forgive me
well look i mean i just i just repeat my
uh my point i i think that
um
i've i overwhelmingly feel it is my job
to get on and uh and deliver and and no
matter how uh bitter and painful the
conclusions of this may be and they are
and no matter how humbling they are i've
i i i've got to uh keep moving forward
and the government's got to keep moving
and we we are and you know just
this week uh we're getting on with
things that again delivering on things
that have been left undone for a very
long time trying to fix the the legacy
uh issues in in northern ireland
incredibly difficult thing to do a
government for decades have have shirked
it uh but we're getting on and doing it
and i was i was pleased to see that um
you know at least you know peter
mandelson is supporting what we're what
we're doing even if the uh the current
opposition
is not
we will get on and continue to do the
tough things